this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody I hope that you
are all well like seven I am I'm Trish
Allah and of course like I said said on
camera and we are coming to you from
Juma private game reserve in of the
Western friend fringes of the Kruger
National Park in South Africa so we are
out on your very own live afternoon
Safari on this wonderful Sunday and
remember that we are interactive so use
that hashtag Safari live to communicate
any of your questions and comments to us
or of course the YouTube chat stream now
I am going to be up in the North at
least starting there and have a look
around the perfect damn area we've got
Tristan and Steve out as well and we're
going to be looking for some spotted
cats now earlier in the day we had a
one-niner nest that was around the
property and she moved west into some
Bambi Lee so that's a bit unfortunate
but it doesn't hurt to check those areas
she might just come back or there might
be other proud members that are still
around so doesn't hurt to just check
those things out which is what we're all
wanting to do today and we're gonna try
and work together to find us some
spotted cats especially it's been awhile
since I have seen or been with a leopard
when I say a while a few days is a while
far as I'm sure you guys all know that
so I'm really hoping that we can see
some tracks and any other signs of those
spotty spotty animals well I hope that
Tristan has gotten some good luck you
know that he is the leopard leopard
whisperer so I really do think that
we'll get some spots on today so let's
go to him and find out how his search is
going
well luck as yet but we do have tracked
both the male and a female if it's not
together moving it out another we
noticed in Ghana because we tracked him
from pretty much where he was seen at
the damn camp
he's busy moving sort of eastwards
towards vultures masala Road and in the
female track crosses the molarity and
that goes more in a northeastly
direction towards befores of dam so he
trying to just head up towards the dam
at the moment to try and see if maybe
both these lipids and headed up there
it's the closest water and I don't think
tin gana drank so we're gonna try and
give it a shot and just see what's
happening now Jamie is calling me on the
radio as well okay Jamie so it's a lots
happening but I should introduce myself
as well my name is this afternoon this
is a very warm welcome now like I said I
was talking to Jamie is so where we
going to be checking Jamie it seems ting
Ghana's cross
east over the mo RT is heading towards
sort of vultures in this area I mean
tracks for this female leopard also
cross the variety and they go more
towards hyena Road same conjunction I'm
just gonna be checking out towards
public Dam and if you want to maybe in
case they turned a bit more south toward
Spaghetti Junction chillin area so we're
just trying to coordinate we were all
going to be
and so we're going to try and see if we
can find one of these lipids if not both
and then hopefully you also try and see
if we can find some lines that we have
seen at the gates this morning by Lauren
on her way out the problem was is that
went to some mobility side but the guy
saw me there was only two lines on their
sides so I wonder if maybe the race the
pride is not still on our side somewhere
so I think Jamie is gonna go and scratch
in that area and see if she can get
lucky with that with in the meantime
we're going to try and see if we can
find ting Ghana or whoever this female
is it seems like a you know parent you
outside and we had blue also crossing
south part of it's been happening
Megan funny
to tell you well good afternoon good
morning good evening everybody sorry for
just losing Tristan there we are in the
middle of nowhere and signal sometimes
can be a problem my name is Steve I'm
joined by Craig on camera welcome to
another Sunday afternoon with us live
here in Juma Game Reserve and well we
are also looking for some content to
this afternoon although we're gonna
focus a little bit more on the western
side and then check our western boundary
to see if there's any sign potentially
of what was that of lions coming in
because this morning one of our staff
members are on the way out the gate and
they actually saw a lioness cross west
from Juma into sunburned belly so who
knows the weather is not that warm so it
is always potential for these large
predators to be moving when days are
like this but who knows there are tracks
of leopards all over the place as Justin
has told you it's in Ghana was seen
under the damn cab we were out tracking
for quite some time this afternoon and
as I went back to get relieved by Jaime
who was coming out we got a report from
some of our lovely viewers that there
was a leopard on the damn cat and I'm
not sure if anyone actually saw him but
he disappeared and his tracks on our
making sure didn't work again don't
worry Justin's got it in him no doubt he
will be able to make head or tail of
where the Juke of Juma is gone but we
are on our western side and this is a
road that I've often had a lot of luck
with Hawker Moody
so just having one little effort there
was a report I believe that he did come
in this morning but it's really hard to
say without being out myself
and seeing the tracks
Jennifer you want to know well we would
definitely want to eat can you see it
there it's just an Impala craggy jennife
you won't have seen Garner's eaten
anything recently and Jennifer I got
back from leave the day before yesterday
so I haven't even seen a leopard yet
since I've been back so unfortunately I
can't tell you but I have no doubt
Kangana has been eating constantly
probably off the property judging by the
number of sightings this week
I'm sure he's eaten many many times on
Juma Craig have you seen it in Ghana you
teen this week I'm sure he must have
been he doesn't go very long without
eating and that impalas just disappeared
if we try and snack one of those but
he's been following a female so we had
tracks this morning of a male or should
I say this afternoon a new heart who's
following a female there was some talk
or speculation from Erickson our game
scout this morning that potentially was
mating leopards by the tracks
we were not had look but too many
vehicles by that stage had been driving
around so we didn't really get to see
the same sort of evidence that was seen
this morning and we know that in Ghana
doesn't just follow females for mating
he also follows them to steal their food
poor young males doesn't really matter
he'll steal anybody's food so I have no
doubt he has been a snacking away
leopards don't generally go for longer
than a couple of days without eating and
it's also the amounts of little things
that they probably eat that we had we
don't see the scrub here's the
Franklin's we just have a look at this
little family I've been parlor over here
you guys in the area of kumuda I wonder
if they know that if they can smell the
difference between different leopards
like leopards can why eanes can i ena
can most certainly smell a leopard and
know exactly who it is by the tracks and
by the the obviously the smell when
different impala can defer and share the
difference between a different leopard
or that just go danger alarm bells just
go off that's very interesting thought
but that's also interesting to see where
the in parlors are we sort of up under
the crest now you can see that by the
trees that are around is in parlor all
the large leaves bush willows bush
willow trees or losing their leaves
there's generally not too much food up
here this time of years all the leaves
start to fall off so it's very likely
that the Impala probably just moving
through this area through the still
fringe and then heading down towards the
right over there where there's probably
a little bit more grazing and browsing
for them and Impala and the road is
looking very interested at something
Craig oh look at that that sort of
behavior is when impalas are moving they
might see something and if it starts
snorting weird if we go and go and
investigate but while we try to figure
out what exactly is going on over here
we're gonna send you back up to the
North around bovis exempt with Shoshanna
I am doing you much of the same doing
some investigation looking for tracks
and I've seen some female leopard tracks
and some lion tracks but they both seem
fairly old so I do not follow up on them
in fact they looked a couple days old
let's take the next one so I'm almost at
before suit damn so I'm looking forward
to seeing what it is actually like
because last few days I've been spending
time in the south and in the West so I
haven't been up here to actually get a
good look at what the water looks like
and I'm sure you guys have and it must
be quite manky I would imagine
and I'd love to see house scuba and
snorkel Sarah doing
now the way that Steve was going about
trying to figure out if hookah movie was
around and making use of the animals
around him to try and give him an idea
of whether he thinks as a predator
around is an excellent excellent way to
do it because if you're out in here in
the bush and you listen carefully and
you watch carefully and even if you
smell carefully all that comes together
and then eventually you found or you
find what you're looking for okay so
coming up on the dam now and it is not
looking great I must say
are you guys are wondering what is the
most difficult animal to actually track
that's a tough one
lots of animals are difficult to track
because it's it's really about the skill
and about whether you can you know it's
so much it's luck skill and timing to
make sure that you're there at the right
place at the right time so it is it's a
difficult thing in fact I'm gonna throw
that question to you Steve or Tristan
because they would have tracked quite a
lot of things in terms of what we have
tracked so far we thinking of the big
animals you know lions leopards in all
of that but I'm sure they have had many
difficulties tracking some of the
smaller things like porcupine or
aardvark
no we are chan we have a one lap wing I
know
now our lovely hippos not sure and I
think that's a given because that that
water does not look hippo appropriate I
must say definitely doesn't look like a
love nest
another little fellow down there IV you
say that's definitely more than the
puddle I am so inclined to agree with
you it is definitely more than a puddle
rather not more than a puddle let's get
the by nose out see the left wing I
think I see some three-banded plover but
that's why I need to get the bynars out
yep these
or picking away well you know I will
often wonder how the presence or absence
of these hippos is going to affect the
ecosystem in this this little particular
area now obviously for the birds it
doesn't mean too much trouble let their
God know that the presence was that they
were there in the first place
but for things living in the water it
may cause a change now that the hippos
are not in there because hippo dung in
water is a fine line
James you'd like to know if the
Terrapins would move with the hippos or
we get two types of Terrapins yeah we
get the marsh Terrapin that is better
suited to more stable sort of
environments or stable watering all sort
of things something like this and then
you get the serrated hinge Terrapin who
is more acquainted with the ephemeral
player pans that are around so I don't
think they will move with the hippos in
fact whatever the hippos go they're very
likely to have Terrapins there anyway so
it's just the luck of the draw
oh we've gotta love these virtual
Starling over here - now we're talking
about how the hippos will affect the
water here at Buffalo Dam now they can
often the bacteria in the dung can often
cause the or too much of it can cause
the water to become anoxic that is
there's little to no oxygen but in the
same way it can add nutrients that is
from outside of the water into the water
so all these things so it'd be cool to
know exactly how it's changed in terms
of water anyway let me send you over to
Steve and find out how his tracking is
going on
thanks Trisha well the search so far has
brought us to our southern boundary and
we have decided to show you a wonderful
bird seen a girl Lapwing very cool bird
quite a common bird here in Juma but I'd
only seen it before
in the northern Kruger hadn't seen it in
many other places so it's not the most
common of the lapwings all the other
left wings the crowned being probably
the most common share a very similar
habitat to the sky and I was very
excited when I came on my interview and
I found one of these guys on the open
area just by our camp I got very excited
and well we pretty much find them every
day now so it's really interesting how
territory or should I say habitat
preference provides a space for
individuals to sort of be in and it's
probably the case that the crowned
lapwings are very aggressive and
probably aren't complete these guys so
that's why we don't find them as broadly
spread as we do the crown Lapwing but
for the most part a very very similar in
all sorts of design and you can see the
be white belly and the grayish a sort of
plumage on the wings and the body but
then that very nice is sort of front on
the forehead there that white front here
we go hello beautiful
one of the ground nesting birds these
individuals will actually nest just like
that right there on the sand with the
most camouflaged eggs you've ever seen
all of the lap wings have a very similar
sort of design and their eggs are shaped
in a way that don't allow them to roll
away
okay so you're all wondering why this
one is not by the water like the
blacksmith Lapwing that rashanna has
seen well the blacksmith Lapwing has a
preference of water and along water
edges and rivers and dams where is the
crown Lapwing and the cynical Lapwing
occur inland on short grassy areas just
like this one that's not to say we won't
find them near water but their habitat
preference is more for the terrestrial
sort of areas where you have lots of
insects moving through I'll see if I can
find a nice picture of their eggs
sometimes the eggs of these birds are
actually in there the photographs as
well which is always very nice and it's
quite incredible once I found a nest of
actually was a they white-fronted what
was it again anyway it was one of the
lapwings I forget now but it was down by
a river and I found the eggs and then I
went back to get the guests that were
with me and it took me 45 minutes to
find them again not the guests that is
the eggs that's because they look like
little stones they are beautifully
camouflaged and there would just be
there in the middle of the open and of
course my um my cell phone app is taking
a very very long to try and load which
is always frustrating but anyway
sometimes there are books on the way
forward okay it's coming up let's get
into this ceiling a Lapwing here we go
hello in you won't know how many
different types of lapwings in Juma okay
well that's not the most okay
this is actually a well to see if this
works so in we've got the Senegal
Lapwing which is this one just I'll show
you the distribution you can see the
distribution of it they sorry let me try
there we go a just sort of goes along
Kruger National Park all the way down to
through Swaziland down to the northern
oops eastern parts of the country
where is the crown left wing would
probably be most of most of the country
so let me just slap across to the eggs
I'm sorry that I'm there we go there it
is
lying on an egg underneath the thing
that is an egg right under the belly
it is camouflaged as can be you can't
even see it there just senator Bailey it
looks just like the substrates and if
you're walking along you would be very
hard-pressed to spot those okay so in
we've got the synagogue that we we've
got the crown Lapwing here we sometimes
see the wattle Lapwing and they're
definitely the blacksmith those four are
quite common in Juma but there are a
number of other species if I go to the
bird page which is also what's so nice
about this see so we've got all of these
guys here
IV the top one on the right the
synagogue and the wattle the crowned at
the bottom we don't have the
black-winged I thought that was there
and then there's another one whoopsie
wrong way there we go there's the
blacksmith so that blacksmith is at the
top they on the right and excuse me up
in the Maasai Mara I will manage to show
you this one many many times on the
bottom left the spur winged Lapwing we
don't find them here in Juma and they
only occur in very sort of it they
regard as a rare vagrant in South Africa
I've seen them as far south as Malawi
apparently you get them in Zambia as
well and this is the one here the white
crowned Lapwing that's the one whose
eggs are found on the louver River in
the northern Kruger and they only occur
in so many places in the Kruger National
Park let me show you the distribution of
this one now have a look at how sporadic
that distribution is it's very very
limited it doesn't take up as much space
and that's the Zambezi
that right up in the north of there
running across at the North of Zimbabwe
and Botswana so it's a bird that lives
on perennial water sources which
basically means rivers that are flowing
all year round okay I hope that I
haven't seen my name have seen one in
northern Kruger and on the refunds river
in South Africa and that's it
very nice okay so that is a nice little
chat about lapwings and habitat
preference is what it's all about the
blacksmith Lapwing is around all water
sources the white-fronted so why am I
getting that name could infuse now I'm
losing my mind it happens I can't blame
it on the heat today
what crowd left-wing perennial permanent
water sources the ceiling out and the
ground nice open open areas it's just
like kingfishers some kingfishers are on
the water some are in the woodland so
it's all about how they've sort of
speciated and often habitats with
regards to feeding resources is how
these birds differentiate themselves so
when we talk about a bird sort of living
environment we talk about the
fundamental niche which is all of the
available space in the environment that
at organism can live without competition
now competition can either be from a
different species or from the same
species so that competition is very very
important for where you'll find these
animals for example if you took away all
the competition of a bird you'd find
them in a lot more places than they are
but add the competition and then they
have to specialize so then you get what
we call the realized niche which is the
actual area in the landscape that an
organism sort of occurs in and that's
got to do with feeding preferences I
habitat which includes food as well as
breeding sites so without breeding sites
and we got one of the coolest birds in
the world in the red Craig
it is the African the habitat preference
of the Hoopoe is woodland areas where
they are cavities for nesting you won't
find these guys
grasslands unless they are some form of
trees to sort of hide around and to
breed in and then they need a certain
food resource and there are specialized
feeders in their ability to probe and
he's gonna go off the road of course
often the hoop who likes to spend a lot
of time walking there he goes back Greg
walking in the road and you see that
probing beak now they can just pluck
insects off the floor and they're also
capable of pulling sort of worms and
things art so Johannesburg itself has
got lots of apu's just like it does lots
of harded ibises and that's because
there are enormous lawn gardens with
enormous forest see for example ahead as
big as the largest man-made forest in
the world
the habitat has been altered by human
laughs stop and so there's lots of lawn
and when there's lots of lawn with lots
of green grass you get lots of worms and
insects in the lawn and there's trees
everywhere for them to breed and so
that's artificially made but the Hoopoe
and the hardy diet do very well in
johannesburg and probably a couple other
cities in south africa anyway so these
birds will choose preference on how it
suits to them to survive and to breed
and obviously there are areas that have
been manipulated and certain animals
will take advantage over that versus
others example house sparrows okay all
over South Africa where there are people
there we go a very short and sweet end
to that story okay so as I said before
we are going to go and check our western
boundary see if there's any sign of
lions coming back in from the West
because it is TV show nights and while
we do that let's go see heart tree
Charlotte is getting along
oh well would you look at that I wonder
if you will stay will he go he went
always happens oh you're still there mr.
Dongo
so I found a he bird actually I'd love
to see them because when they fly about
in their little bit of insect catching
frenzy it's quite entertaining
especially since you can't see the
insect so all you see it's these acrobat
kind of movements aerial acrobatics and
very likely so he they're just waiting
to catch some insects that have emerged
from this grass the grass looks a little
bit trampled no wonder if that's why
he's yeah it's something disturbed it
because what happens when big animals
come through an area like this and they
disturb the grasses that's what kicks up
all the insects and you'll find that
these insects actually sorry guys I got
really distracted because I realized
what was happening here said I'm so
sorry to swing you around but we have
some Mongoose just playing a little bit
on this end just at the base of the tree
come guys I can hear you Oh what I was
going to say about the insect is the
amount of protein that they can offer
animals that eat them including
ourselves in fact I saw that in Cape
Town they now make insect icecream high
protein ice cream hello you
I could hear so much rustling in the
background and whenever we hear that
kind of thing it's usually always Impala
that they're just walking on by hi and
that also says that we now get
chocolate-covered crickets just the fact
that it's got chocolate on it I may give
it a go hello you are just too sweet
there's been an influx of do off
Mongoose at camp as well and even behind
our rooms they seem to be all over the
place in fact yesterday I had crackers
that I had taken out just before drive
that I was about to eat and a horn ball
- horn balls - starlings and about three
Mongoose all set around me and then
eventually the Womble took a chance and
he took my cracker just one of the
things we have to deal with you know you
just have to deal with it I'll chew in
the bush they seem to be scratching
around just saw some teeth scratching
around probably for the same reason that
the drongo is right yeah because there's
something in the grasses that have been
disturbed that are now emerging and that
they can get a hand on all over the
place so this is what I love about being
in in the bush is that if you sit in one
space long enough things just you start
to see so much happening
Oh Ichigo there's one guy I'd like
swinging safe from left to right and
left to right now there's another guy on
the tree that the drongo was on giving
except a workout today can you see it he
so sweetly says it's okay so it really
must be some sort of proliferation of
some little insect going on here that
all these guys are often you'll see them
foraging together often birds and
Mongoose especially the ones that are
after insects
thank you don't we doing some grooming
there are so many cars on the property
today I don't know if you can hear this
one behind us that if we don't find a
leopard it is not because we didn't have
every single turn a stone unturned but
he's turned off so I don't need to move
thankfully now these two are grooming
themselves just a little bit Oh No
what about Mongoose flavored ice cream
no I don't think I'd be too keen on that
I must say I think ice cream is one of
my favorite foods done hello you you'd
enjoy some insect ice cream wouldn't you
this is their sort of their final forage
for the evening before they settle back
in and they keep really good hours they
go to bed early and wake up late which
is ideal
and they're very very curious it does
have very wide eyes emesis looks like
it's on a sugar high too much ice cream
for you look at this nose go twitch
twitch twitch twitch now I know that you
know that that lions and leopards have
with whiskers scénic you'd like to know
if Mongoose a low groom I have
definitely seen them a low grooming they
are doing it very often and quite
constantly you'll see them groom each
other and then one grooms each other it
happens very often it happens quite a
lot in a social group or society and in
fact in hyena is a bit of an exception
to that because they don't groom each
other they it'll only rarely groom their
cubs in themselves but that's whole
social unit having that brain that's
geared towards living in a social group
means that you have to have other
grooming in order to strengthen your
relationships
little things like apparently pulling
against hair and things like that can
actually stimulate the hormones that are
associated with relationships and and
building long-term bonds so it's really
really interesting
that's something so small but just
because of its unit and the way that
it's needed to develop in order to be
successful as a sec asn't as a social
animal has allowed it to do these things
now I was telling you about whiskers and
how he always really associate whiskers
with your cats or your dogs but whiskers
are sort of throughout the animal
kingdom and while at least with mammals
whiskers is quite it's quite a common
thing you get micro whisker that micro
whiskers and macro whiskers and they
have sort of different jobs the macro
whiskers are the big ones that you see
with your house cat or without our
lipids and then you get little tiny ones
like little little hairs around a chimps
mouth and they help and I was pointing
them out there with a mongoose because
they've also got these little Mike
grow whiskers and then when I go around
like it was moving its nose in all those
directions
that's called whisking and it's when
they try to check out a new place with
those whiskers it's got a very tactile
sensory function so it gives them
information about all the things that
are happening around it and what's
really cool as though it is in a way a
modified way a modified hair it's
thicker and it actually originates from
a different type of follicle and that
follicle is surrounded by blood so each
little bit of information that goes into
that whisker the whisker picks up it
gets amplified by the blood and then
sent into the brain really cool I think
anyway then we send you over to Tristan
and see how that search is going for the
spotted cat
no just their footprints so far so we
kept following these tracks that we've
lost through the mail wind which is
obviously like I say is teen ganas
tracks from where he was seen on the
damn cam so we don't know where he's
gone but the female tracks went to
puffles exam they drank and then it
seems like she's been going east away
from the dam which is not necessarily
good news for us because pretty sure
she's gonna cross out fairly soon if
that's the case now whose tracks are
these is this her coming Archer no
that's not her that's a big hyena
so at this stage it's not really great
news because she's hitting kind of East
right on the northern boundary and the
boundaries are not far away it's all in
so what I'm hoping is that she's drank
and decided just to lie down but this
cats has walked an absolute mile during
the course of today it's been a fairly
kulish day it hasn't been too hot and so
conditions have boats have been pretty
good for walking and maybe that's why
we're seeing so much movement from her
today but I mean she's walked pretty
much from Zoey's Road which is in the
western side of jummah and she's crossed
all the way along to the northeastern
corner Vicki do I think ten years in
eustress I am not sure to be honest I
haven't spent any time with her I
haven't seen her since I've been back so
it's very difficult to say whether or
not she's in Easter asur what's actually
going on with her I'm afraid
unfortunately because of not spending
time with her you know you can't see
what her behavior is what she's doing is
she calling is she sent marking but what
I will tell you is that this leopard had
we've been tracking she has sent mark to
Lots she looks like she's been going up
against bushes and kind of scenting and
then turning and scenting and turning
and same thing and so maybe it is her
and maybe she's coming into mr. cycle
and that's why
is kind of moving with males and various
other things it's possible but until we
find the cats it's always very difficult
to know exactly what lipid you're
tracking I'm not one of those that kind
of picks up the idiosyncrasies of
individual lipid tracks they are some
that are far better at those kind of
things than what I am but yes apparently
some people can and do you pick up track
have you got something very male track
these are yesterday's mail tracks I'm
afraid so that's also the other problem
is now because it's winter a lot of the
tracks and you can pick them up quite
often the next day and they still look
really good because you don't have too
much rain or anything like that
and because the ground is so powdery
they still stay quite defined so you
would just be a bit careful with tracks
but there's a male lipid that works all
the way along he sa which I suppose was
Dingaan er and then rain suitable for
soaked and then turned back and came
astounds me as how far these lipids can
cover even in the middle of the day I
mean the tracks that's this of this
female on top of this morning's game
drive tracks a long long way but
hopefully we'll find it and essentially
where the tracks are soft are left hand
side there's a drainage line that runs
from befores of dam and seems like she's
going east in that drainage time now
that's an area that tungee very
regularly goes and so it wouldn't
surprise me if it is her she stored
Columbia in this drainage line for quite
a bit in January February of last year
so it's very very possible that she's
been there now it's also very close to
where I had a visual of a leopard
yesterday I still don't even know if it
was male or female to be honest with you
guys
tracks look like female so ice I expect
it to be a female but it crossed into
buffers look very close to where I am
right now
on the boundary so we had a very brief
now it sounds like the guys are saying
their butts in parlors alarm calling it
quarantine which is quite interesting
say I have to see right now that sounds
like Trish is having all the luck
without animals we might get a little
shift towards quarantine to see if those
impalas are shouting about in the
meantime though back across to Trish on
yes input in exciting and important
things seem to be happening a quarantine
there's some alarm calls so I hope that
Tristan will get there and you'll find
something exciting but in the meantime
we do have a lovely male and Jana here
and you can see that his outline is
quite jagged at the moment and that is
because he has just been displaying or
showing off to another male he goes
behind the bush
he's just been showing off behind to
another male so I just saw these two
males you know just casually they looked
like normal you know like that we're
just gonna have a snack but instead they
start to move very slowly and unison and
then the hairs all were erect and that
happens when they want to display to
each other and decide who is better than
the other one and who is going to get to
mate now nyada's will make throughout
the year but it sort of does reach a
peak in the jjang between January and
May mostly so this might be the last few
guys that are trying to get their
genetics pushed ahead this season maybe
we can catch a last glimpse of him as he
walks away you can get to see the nice
crest on his back he's starting to lower
it a little bit now but when we first
saw when we first saw it it was quite
high even the tail was fluffy DJ you say
you like a good in yalla dance oh
there's nothing like a good in yaller
dance
at first you don't even know what's
happening and then you look carefully
you think what you're dancing can see is
a nice mature bull nice big horns and
the white tips at the top as well
lovely so having some luck finding all
the smaller or less shown creatures now
pilo erection is something that we also
do
it's very strange you'd think that we
don't ah some of you guys are wondering
if antelopes also have some form of
whisper whispers whiskers that is a
really good question I don't know
specifically to antelope but I do know
that most mammals do and it's easier to
count the animals that are it's easier
to count the animals that don't have
them than it is to count the animals
that do in terms of mammals so it's very
likely that they do and if you look at
their chin and the area around their
mouths you can see there's small sort of
short hairs so it wouldn't surprise me
if they if they do also have whiskers
per se now we also have remnants of days
when we used to have whiskers yes we
certain people still have little
muscular areas in the upper lip that
where they would have developed whiskers
eight hundred thousand years ago existed
but like I said even with pilo ear X you
know here's another guy
even with pilo erection it is not just
these guys that do it we do it too when
you get a bit of a fright sore you feel
the hairs on the back of your neck
rising or you get cold those are forms
of pilar erection because by definition
there's a tiny little muscle tiny tiny
tiny at the base of each one of those
valla curls and it lifts the hair it
contracts to lift the hair and that's
exactly what happens in us when we get
cold now compare the this guy's crest on
his back which is fairly relaxed and
flat against his body compared to the
one that we just saw that
displaying to the other male that's nice
this must be a nice feeding area for
them because there are three of them
around you can see those distinctive
over the knee socks kind of look this
one has really distinctive White's white
stripes oh the one white stripe is
really thick and prominent that's cool
Ian you'd like to know if animals have
goose bumps then well I suppose in
actual fact it is goose bumps because
they are trying to do the same thing
that we are trying to do and when in a
time where we would have been cold and
exposed the pile erection of our hairs
on our arms and our legs would have kept
us warm and helped us to insulate
ourselves and that's what these animals
do when it's cold as well the difference
is they have another use for it and that
is to make themselves appear bigger and
stronger when they're displaying to
somebody of the some of the same species
that they wish to fight with and I'm
sure in our case when we were way way
way way way back when when we were just
developing probably not even us but
earlier species of Homo would have done
the same thing in a way if they had
thick body hair which usually got it was
lost pretty recently in the home pretty
early in the homo lineage but earlier
animals would have had thicker hair and
it would have also acted as making them
look bigger and heavier and probably
more muscular
we're all connected in very different
weird strange ways by whiskers of Bracy
and even via pilo erection
Courtney you'd like to know neeyala have
a rutting season like Impala they don't
particularly do they breed throughout
the year and you'll find that it's
usually Peaks and around January to May
so that's why when I saw the other ones
displaying earlier I thought that it
might just be some last guys trying to
get in before the season or before the
peak of the season sort of ends but they
don't have a rutting per say in the same
way as Impala do
very cool I always think the fluffy tail
is very very cute
he looks like he slightly has picked up
his back the hairs on his back but I'd
still think that he is fairly relaxed I
feel like he is looks a little younger
than the guys that were fighting earlier
on I say fighting they were very very
slowly trying to size each other up all
right well while he eats away I am going
to keep on going I am now on the eastern
boundary so I'm going to come down a
little bit and get back on unto the main
road that's the southern boundary and
then come back into Juma and go past
twin dams have a look at what's there
by any other friend
niala are beautiful they're stunning
they look like little almost very very
forest kind of creatures I could imagine
them alongside some toadstools
okay we are on to the camera killer Road
again but luckily it's not too far Drive
it's just a short distance the meantime
let me send you over to Steve who's
looking at something on the road
well thank you to Charlotte here on the
East we are on the west and there's
tracks of three Alaia nests that
seemingly came from the drummer side and
this is the western boundary road and
they came into the road and then crossed
over onto our left-hand side so the
objective was because we heard there was
a lioness well one of our staff members
saw one this morning right yep towards
the gate saw one crossing this road yeah
it's quite tricky for tracking because
it's the main a thoroughfare for most
the lodges in and out so the only tracks
you can see are the ones just on the
side of the road that haven't been
driven on so our objective was to come
here to see if maybe any of those
animals have come back again and at the
moment they have gone west that is worth
checking so we have an idea of where
they're going one here and two over
there crossing in that direction keep
going up a little bit see if this any
joy and then we're gonna have to make
another plan for what we're gonna do but
at least we've checked our western
boundary and what a wonderful afternoon
it is to be out so we were talking about
birds alien about habitat preference and
the reason why I wanted to bring that up
is that if you ever do now see a bird
that kind of looks like something you
might have seen before then go to the
page of plumbers or kingfishers or
whatever it might be in it bear in mind
where are you are you along a river is
the permanent River is that a pan is it
a swamp is that an open grassland is it
a forest and then with that habitat
preference in the bird identification
you'll be able to know exactly which
species you're looking at because once
you know what a Taraka looks like you
will be able to identify all the
trackers you might just be like I don't
know who this is but it looks like good
Soraka or it looks like a Kingfisher and
then once you find the habitat
preference then it's very easy very good
so not only do we have to look at the
birds beaks and feets and all of those
feets feet and beak we need to look at
also where
you find them because that is one of the
defining characteristics of speciation
of how the birds or animals have
occurred where they are because of the
competition between them for food
resources as well as predators sort of
keeping them see for example this bird
right over here it is on the ground it
has got a very long horn like beak and
the beak is red and well challenges are
things we need to take on and yes of
course the birds feet do often look
similar for example now you can't really
see this one's legs but if you look
closely they are quite a dark in color
there's nothing really too much - the
legs is there but the beak very easy to
see that it is red and it's got a horn
like shape so if you've never seen it
this particular bird before but maybe
you've seen others of the family that is
indeed a hornbill about bear in mind you
get horn balls all over the country so
where are you if you're in the Kruger
National Park you'll be able to
differentiate this from a bird that you
might find in Namibia for example you
get similar birds across in Namibia that
look very similar to the red-billed horn
ball I'll actually even show you but
bearing in mind where you are in the
country that obviously makes a very big
a very important characteristic isn't it
where are you and then where are you
right now so right now we look around
it's kind of a mixed woodland here
there's nothing too special about it
and quite easily then if it's a special
bird only occur in a very specialized
sort of place now what I wanted to show
you on my phone here which is going to
make it quite tricky if you are new to
this because let's have a look at the
horn bull Paige
we at the gate you can probably hear at
one of the anti-poaching dogs bark in
there look at all the birds at the top
with the red beak there's one there's
two there's three there's four birds
actually with red beaks
but now how are we going to tell the
default the difference between the
southern red built the Damara red built
the Montero's hornball it's very tricky
isn't it but if I go and I click on the
Montero's which is up here in our
distribution look at where it occurs
there up in Namibia on the west coast so
it's not that guy is it now if we click
the damara distribution there we go once
again also up in Namibia now what could
it be could it be this front the
Bradfield's let's have a look because we
don't really know our Birds Bradfield's
occurs all at the northern mobian
northern Botswana even up into Angola so
no definitely not him and they have a
look at this one this one's got a red
beak this is the crowned now look at
that one okay wow that possibly could be
it
couldn't it look at the dark the
distribution but if we go more into the
bird and we just have a look at its bird
page and it will tell us tall closed
canopy woodland and forest well we're
not really in a tall closed canopy
woodland and forests are we they are
places in the Kruger National Park where
you do find at the crown hornball I've
only heard them now I haven't heard them
have heard trumpets a horn Bulls here I
haven't seen crowned they need very very
long tall trees with very very wet River
on areas so it is definitely not the
crown horn Balin if we go to the
southern red belt let's have a look at
the bird page we obviously already know
where he occurs the car largest
distribution is so if you were up in
Namibia up over here you could possibly
confuse him with one of those other
individuals but what is nice about these
apps is see it says they're smaller than
the damara red-faced horn ball tomorrow
red bull horn bomb with a gray streaked
face and yellow eye so if you are up in
Namibia and you were confused between
those two then there's a few more things
you need to look for but what do we got
your habitat open woodland and that's
where we are open woodland of the
savannas are quite a common bird for yes
so this very small little blurb
yeah it gives you a lot of information
about the bird a lot about their food
and where you might find them and if you
keep going further down there's so much
more information
Lauren Your Honor if there's anything
different between the yellow and the red
build well I think the yellow is a
slightly bigger their beaks are a little
bit bigger as well and they do actually
share very very similar habitat also
here wide range of savannas and more
closed woodland so there's probably a
huge overlap between the two we do find
them often in mixed feeding groups I
think the two of them are very very
similar in their design they also feed
on the same sort of foods so they kind
of push each other around that suppose I
think the yellow bulbs are maybe a
little bit more aggressive but
speciation how this be said it's quite
tricky they're both fitting into a niche
because the savannah is quite a broad
ecosystem and they are both specialists
they're able to use their beak for for
sifting through leaf matter they're able
to switch from insects to fruit to
flowers and all that sort of thing so
they're quite a specialized bird and
also the nest and cavities and the trees
which need woodland for that and that
enables them to be quite successful but
a very very similar bird but there are
some slight differences but when you see
the beak and one is the flying banana
the other one's the flying chilli so you
shouldn't confuse them too easily
okay well our job on the West here is
done now for now we're going to just pop
in and see if anything's going on
towards Sydney's down there but while we
do that let's go back over to Trish ala
see if she's having any luck on the
eastern side
I have come across this little darling
and we are add to twin dams now so I'm I
was really happy to see that there was
something happening yeah because most of
the time especially when the water is as
low as no is at the moment you don't see
much happening here look at that all of
that is dry all of them has a potential
to be fold up and all we have is that
little muddy patch on the left
but this hyena obviously likes to be
near the water but not near enough now
I'm trying to figure out who this is and
I'm really not sure at this point now I
saw a glimpse of the right ear and it
did have a knotch taken out of it so I
wondered if it was hard but isn't gonna
come very clear look but I think it may
be hard it's a really distinctive red
tuft of hair on the head there
it looks quite
punk rocker
she is semi relaxing oh yes I think that
is what it's International redhead day
today that's what Emma tells me and this
is its international redhead day and for
those of you who don't know emma is a
redhead so happy international redhead
dates you Emma and to you
hyena I think I'm just I'm sure this is
hot now when I'm pretty sure it is
what who emma is waiting for her present
you just watch I'll bring you some red
hair from a hyena Emma you can attach it
onto your own Oh Sybil now we're looking
at her awkward back legs and how stumpy
it looks I suppose this is what happens
when you just want to relax it's like
when you fall asleep and you in your
arms are underneath your body on on your
tummy it's that awkward I'm so tired and
I just need to sleep
she's breathing quite heavily too but
also this kind of stance or position
while lying down means that that then
vascularized tissue on the underneath of
the of the belly can actually touch the
ground and start to cool down the rest
of the body so even though it looks a
bit awkward a bit funny it's actually
very effective
looks so cool so peaceful
all righty let me send you over to
Tristan and find out how he's tracking
is going I might pop into the den in a
little bit well she's not very good I'm
afraid
nipples are playing all kinds of games
with us today is alarm calls is tracks
there's everything but no sign of the
actual individuals and all three of them
I say it's because I think the tracks
are for three different individuals or
messing around all over the place really
so we're just gonna have to be patient
I'm just doing a big loop at the moment
because I still think before Zach dam is
going to be a good place to go the
tracks that we had on y'all are at north
going to perfect and we're just so fresh
that they looked like they were going to
pop arts there somewhere and so I'm
hoping that that's going to be the case
Dingaan I have no idea where he's gone
he's somehow vanished and there seems to
be another lipid moving around somewhere
close to camp which I suppose could be
tagged on and it's very very impossible
as well so it's been a frustrating
afternoon in many respects given that we
know that they yeah we just haven't been
able to lay eyes on them just yet but
it's this time of the day that a lipid
starts to really move and starts to kind
of go and look for water as the Sun is
setting and so it seems like a good time
to be art and looking for our spotted
kitties like I say I'm gonna do a bit of
a change and go all the way down to
u-turn dams quickly just have a little
look there in case some little leopard
has decided to move in particularly
Tigana
you know how much he likes to walk in
sometimes he came in with a sneak off so
you gonna have a quick just scan for him
and then back up to before Zook damn
again
and see if we can pick up anything Fiona
we do need a little bit of leopard magic
I find lip adventure comes when you try
harder new patients and you don't give
up hope and I find that that's when you
get it and so we're going to try our
very very best to just keep positive and
hopefully at some point in if it's gonna
pop out somewhere between myself and
Trish and Jamie's out at the moment
helping and Steve I feel like we've got
an opportunity to maybe find something
somewhere along the line here I think we
just got it like I say being a little
bit patient and really just sort of sits
in wait and hope I'm pretty sure
something will come out and some point
it's one of those things though if it
doesn't it doesn't this is how life goes
and how wildlife areas are often people
you know citizen will think that because
we're in the sabi sands it's a given
that you're going to go and see
everything that you want to see that's
not always the case sometimes it takes a
lot of hard work and a bit of patience
and not getting frustrated with things
and then actually you can get what you
are looking for and so you know quiet
days do happen Archer and they make you
appreciate him it's not quiet so it's
not the worst thing in the world at some
point somebody he's going to come up
with the goods I'm backing that it's
gonna be 10 Ghana or Columba that I'm
gonna make an appearance tonight so I
think Tandy has made quite a few but she
when was the last time he was seen
actually I'm sure she wasn't seen that
long ago there's been a few sightings of
Nate
and so hopefully she'll be arts as well
it wouldn't be nice we had all three of
them
right turndowns what have you got for us
is very quiet no in parlors which is
sometimes a good sign don't see anything
23rd was the last tündi sighting mm-hmm
what are we today too long ago three
days ago that's not bad
so she's doing appearance
wouldn't it be nice if Sabri was yeah we
cool awesome I saw it was right yeah
it'd be nice well not quite right yet
about a hundred meters in something
where I am right now
what's that there that is a hyena that
is lying there that is not a leopard for
a second day I got excited
it's no wonder there is no impalas
around us like I said when there's no
impalas at turndowns at this time of the
day you know something is lurking and so
on the northern side of the dam lying
down and it must be you there how you
know that Trish just saw and now so
there we go you can see it lying down
there it's typically win like I say if
you had one of these dams and you don't
find any impalas around or any sort of
prey animals can often be a sign that
there is a predator around and well you
know is one of those even though they
have this reputation of being thought to
be scavengers we know very differently
that they are very much able to do
hunter now immerse is to me that this
hyena looks like she feels hey are you
having the sunday blues what's going on
is it because it's red hair day
that's your upset em is a redhead by the
way they mustn't be upset you must
celebrate the fact that you have been
here well there is not really red hair
she's got more more kind of we didn't
get you presents but it's because it's
your birthday in a few days time I'll
know a few days away is the 15th of June
is it Emma 15th of June maybe no could
be don't think so not sure that would be
correct and there we go
see so I've got brownie points for
remembering him as birthday but she says
she needs she's disappointed because she
wants it to presence once a day for
redhead day and two for her birthday but
that's just being greedy because I
suppose you also want to present on your
Christmas too and you can't have
presents all the time well I suppose
this will but it could theoretically
claim birthday month in which case
people would have to
do you say right well you left our you
know alone because you've discussed it
with with attrition we are on a
different kind of mission and it's the
right time for me to be hitting towards
before so damn now now's the time for me
to go there and repair rabbits out the
Hat what do you think John Dre writes
now the reason I snipped this idea and
why I'm leaving it's is because I want
to go find a little bit but she wants to
go and find my Enid in and so she's off
in that direction and hopefully she'll
have some luck I have a full faith that
Tristan will be able to pull a bunny out
of the Hat tonight if not for a leopard
it will it will definitely be a scrum
here out of that hat but I'm heading to
the hyena den I'm heading to the
[Music]
exciting den the first end or okay I say
the first didn't started spot first in
the so but still it was one of the new
word in are the ones before this these
two that we have now and the ensuite ten
there we go the den or the splash pool
double storied in that one we're going
to have one because that's where I saw
June's Cubs yesterday so I want to just
check maybe they're around and then if
there's nobody there we'll pay a visit
to the other day and see if Ruben and
her two are around
I feel like they moved from this den
because it was there were lots of big
game that was coming around there were
the Buffalo outside they were elephants
around awfully nice remember being at
the den and you'll see a elephant walk
by and the Cubs are out and playing and
the parents are I'm the mums are around
as well but they not didn't seem very
concerned but I suppose it's not the
most safest thing for to have all those
all the big game you don't want them to
be trampling your Cubs Linda you say we
need to have a discussion about how many
different dens they are and where they
are and when they moved well I can give
you my two cents so when we first got
you in October last year it was a den on
Aubrey's road which is pretty much
central ish Juma an opossum camp then
they went to Philemon Scotland in which
is when we get to the den that we're
going to now we entered through that
roads it's also a little more south of
central area then they moved to the
stand that we're gonna be approaching
now and then from there they've moved to
the two dens that we see ribbon and her
Cubs in often okay this excuse this part
yeah it looks so neat yeah so says if
the hyenas landscape the area doesn't it
look very neat
let's have a look
I thought I saw a pair of ears poking
out did you see them same here let us
have a look
okay so we're just gonna have a quick
glance as we drive through because there
aren't any adults around but June's two
are here so as I slowly we will stop for
one moment just have a look at them and
then we will be off there these two now
they've been hanging out at its den two
days now that I've seen them here by
themselves so I'm going to assume that
this is where then and Jun is hanging
about
look at these distinctive spots on the
back almost as if they've merged into
stripes a bit okay pop it I think we
have to go we are drawing you out now
and that is no good I'm sorry guys trust
me I am also sad about it
buh-bye puppets we'll see you another
time when mums around that was nice
because you were with me as I went round
to check you could actually catch a
glimpse of them so that was sweet all
right let me make my way to the other
den and go past treehouse Dam at the
same time and see what's going on there
and the meantime I'll send you over to
Steve so he can tell you a little bit
more about what's going on with him
what's going thanks Tricia well you're
back with us everybody we found some
more Lion tracks and a leopard track
just after you left us and they both
came back into juma and then we went
around towards Sydney's dam area which
is on the North sort of eastern corner
to see if maybe they went out that way
and all we did by doing that was find
where the rest of the pride had been
moving earlier but no sign yet of
possibly where these individuals could
be we're just heading back towards sort
of retail access taking it very very
slowly because as I said before I only
saw tracks of three lions going over and
then track of one coming this way with a
leopard I don't think they were doing it
at the same time
and then when we came here there's at
least six Lions that have headed in this
direction but don't think they've
crushed so we might be lucky right here
up in the northern sort of by the gates
should I say it's very hard to really
give you an exact cardinal point but
just popping out sure here's our main
access in here to Juma scared to go
around the corner and see if maybe these
lines are just lying up remember when I
just before went to the Mara we had the
vocal males with a couple of uncle
homers and they were just yep
in the thickets a very tricky place to
be because where we are is right on the
sort of tip of jummah with the other
properties with the gate there man you
lady before sook it's just a very
interesting sort of triangle up here in
a an area that the animals can really
cross through very quickly because it's
a very short distance it's not far at
all so if they just walk across the road
there there it could probably throw a
stone well some somebody could probably
throw a stone from that road to that
road over there but I probably couldn't
throw a stone in that fire how about you
Craig maybe maybe but further than first
anticipated but let's keep searching
keeping our eyes peeled
and we are okay here is the tracks of
the pride that we probably showed you a
couple before you can see there's one
there's probably two there's definitely
a male there and then a female over here
so that's two individuals but it's
possible that they split up these are
probably two of the individuals that we
already counted crossing over but then
we had one crossing back again it is
also possible that they were playing
frequences area isn't very difficult to
cross they could have gone back and back
again it's very hard to say with that
physically beam yeah at the time well
one thing for sure is they're crossing
the strait and that is where we were
showing them to earlier that is triple-m
the boundary right so we're just gonna
scratch around here for a few more
minutes see if we can have any luck as
the Sun starts to descend in the West
that's the beautiful thing about being
out on game Drive is you never know what
you could find you know this this area
sort of a northern section this sort of
area in the northern section here
doesn't get as much sort of vehicle
traffic as it probably should and a lot
of animals cross here very quickly a lot
of you are wondering about Avoca updates
yes so the voters have been around I
haven't seen him since obviously ours
here lost some but there was one on last
night restore yesterday morning was
found just south of our boundary and
they've been walking through but just
the males have got such large
territories that jhummer for them is
just a drop in the ocean and they just
have to just walk in but they're on the
other side that is the difficulty okay
see here we are once again directly at
the gate and no Lions to be seen but we
will slowly drive back down this way and
it's possible that maybe with the
setting of the Sun let's check the wind
shall we wind direction it is very
gently coming from that side very gently
coming this way so what that means to me
is that Lions will always move sort of
in the direction of the wind I walk
across wind so if the winds come in this
way they'll walk that way or that way
and then as soon as I smell something I
walk back so with the wind coming from
that direction the problem will mean
they'll go that way that's probably why
they've gone that way and yes Emma does
work you got to lick your finger and put
it up in the air and the cold side is
the side the wind is coming from but if
you do it while you're driving it
doesn't work because obviously the wind
from the driving is what's making your
finger cold
that's why I stopped the car and
switched off - there are no external
influences like right now the wind is
coming from that way because that's the
way I'm driving while this thing over
here is called a windscreen we generate
our own wind especially when we put our
foot down Emma says she's been testing
window wrong the entire time and the key
is also him as the finger that you lick
you've got to stick up if you put up
another finger well just doesn't work
the best way really to do is with ash in
a sock that gives a very good indication
of wind or little grass seeds or scrub
hair dung is a very very good one just
don't leave them in your pockets and
wash them it doesn't it's not a very
good result okay so the Lions are
walking down here you'll see the tracks
crossing the road and then heading into
that direction I sort of general you can
see what I mean while we look on the
side of the road because the middle of
the road now where everybody drives
there's no tracks but just that little
band on the outside where it's nice and
soft is where they're walking and their
general direction you can see is is
heading in that direction there and
across but who knows they could have got
a cross and laid down just off yeah
we've had it a little while ago where
the Inca Hummers were lying up in a tree
right over there next to the road it was
quite a difficult place to be because
when you have lions right here under the
boundary then all of the lodges from the
Sun that side have access in case you
weren't sure it was lion there is a very
nice sort of track and sign right over
there in the form of lion scat and
people who tell you that lions don't
have white in their dung well they've
never seen lions get before the easiest
way to tell lion vs. hyena is this pinch
over here is it'll twist at the end
there weird pinches out and it is also
well both of them will have fur in it
but hyenas are more segmented
they're actually at the end of the the
scatter it comes out forms a little
shape like a nipple rather than that of
a pinch there we go at the end of this
one over here as well you can see that
little pinch at the end there it's very
characteristic of leopards and lions so
lots and lots of bone in their diet this
time of year probably ate an entire
young Impala that's right so white but
very good news Tristan Dix is on the
other end and after all his hard hard
work has got a surprise for you
it's very very good to news as you can
see we've managed to catch up with the
Duke who is nothing but play games today
by the looks of things and had it not
been for some baboons and some very good
work by Texan I don't think we would
have found him this evening because he
is right in the middle of a block which
is basically a area surrounded by road
and so I think it let's call it that to
basically great straight east of the dam
and the baboons were giving him a hard
time particularly a big male baboon that
was chasing him and so he ended up
unfortunately being chased and pushed on
and being sent all the way to the east
which is good but at least we caught up
with him so very very good news
hopefully it's going to be Havel himself
and not going to too many thickets where
we go from here is not going to be very
easy at all it's very very very dense
and lots and lots of thickets now you
might notice that there's a few flashes
and and some spotlights and that's
because there is a photographic group
that is here at the moment so um I hope
that won't put you off too much but if
you suffer from any sort of triggering
that causes any sort of problems with
your health with flashing lights and
it's probably a good time to look away
but anyway um very pretty John right
with the highlighted grass and Pingala
that's going to move through it he looks
pretty good though yeah I mean doesn't
he looks like he could do with a meal
and he certainly looks like he's on the
hunt at the moment he's moving quickly
he keeps stopping listening getting low
and then starting to kind of creep as he
goes so he definitely looking as though
he's hunting try keep up with him
because I see any be trotting or finale
leave or so a lots of you of full of
elation and apparently even tears on the
chat no not sure we should be crying
just yet stole the night's is early and
we have not yet spent five minutes with
the Duke and he seems like he's in one
of those moods where he wants to put us
through our paces and test us
which is going to be tricky because this
block is as James Hindry would say not
for ants that's James can be saying what
are you watching ting gana he's stalking
an Impala just go back for you Chandra
so if you look good I can just see the
back of an Impala just to the right of
where he is say he's then you can see
his attitude he's got his head down and
his ears kind of cocked not to the front
or right of him it's gonna be very
tricky to see it but you see there's
some bushes way in the distance there
the Impala just went behind that front
sort of Bush on the top right of your
screen
he's really but now has also that's
basically what he's after at the moment
so that's what he's stalking we're gonna
sit now and we're gonna be very very
very quiet and we're not gonna make too
much noise and attract keep our lights
off him as much as possible the vehicle
next to us is going to do the same as he
tries to now close the gap between the
Impala and himself now you can see how
this movement works it's incredible
watching a leopard when they do this
they get nice and low and the ears face
forward and they rely heavily on that
spotted camouflage that they've got you
can see the Impala is completely
oblivious to his presence at the stage
there's the Impala that I first saw
that's slowly moving off and it is at
this time of the year that the impalas
are rutting and so rutting oh no he's
going to get seen if he keeps moving he
hasn't watched from hmm and in part on
the left looks as though it's seen him
you see that no something is there but
it's not sure what just yet I wouldn't
be surprised it starts to alarm call
pretty short beep Tinky keep your head
down
isn't that a ridiculously good shot
Elton John Dre very nice to have the
tude kind of facing off another but that
Empire knows that there's something not
right ahead of it and ting he was a bit
casual in the way that he was walking
even when that Impala put up its head
while it was feeding it's not a problem
but as soon as they popped the head up
well you need to kind of have a little
bit more con circumspect movements I
would say is probably the best way to
put it and to try and kind of keep his
head down as much as possible I just
want to see there we go you see that
impalas seen him you hear it alarm
calling so unfortunately for him there
we go he's got no chance I'm afraid that
Impala has seen him and although the
impalas kind of not run off and it's
just kind of meandering off give Tigana
another crack at it but the fact that it
was an alarm calling is generally
indicative of that it's actually seen
him yeah and it is a very sassy and
Polly you write him a bit of swag to
that impalas kind of shot sitting on and
it's like well I'm just going to stroll
off I don't care what you think about
life so interesting to kind of see you
still kind of got his head down because
maybe the Impala might not have actually
seen him properly might just have smelt
him or thought maybe that's he's there I
mean given a few alarm calls and the
fact that the others haven't a long cold
means that maybe ting honestl in with
the shot when it comes to hunting so if
he's patient and just sits very very
quietly
maybe these impalas will start to relax
and he can have another go and move and
try and refigure out where he is
so safari hours maybe they were having a
blinking competition well looks like it
didn't is er to have him kind of just
staring at each other at one point and
maybe that is exactly what has happened
I fear though that's ting Ghana has lost
the competition given that he
unfortunately twitched and that good
means he got shot to death maybe that's
a disqualify if you twitch oh yeah
there's still another Impala that's they
straight ahead of him and you can see
just walking around through this maybe
if he's just waits for it to get a bit a
little bit dark yet still obviously
quite bright and the Sun has set but
there's residual lights and if he waits
a little bit in the cover of darkness he
might have a better shot and actually
hunting these guys and being able to
kind of go after them it's been very
interesting is that this block that he's
in at the moment this area that he's in
should I say is a space where he spins
quite a lot of time when he's hunting
and he often goes to all the little
burrows that are in here saying earlier
that it's got a lot of odd farc holes in
this area which means there's a lot of
warthogs out of our fog and so he spends
a huge amount of time sitting at those
holes so in the last sort of few weeks
before I went on leave I think had about
four sightings of Tenggara in this very
area and every single one of them would
start at this time of the day and he
kind of got in and then he would start
to hunt and he'd find a little halt and
then you'd sit at that hole and you just
patiently stared on it and wait until
something was hopefully going to come
out and so maybe he'll abandon these
same parlors and move kind of soft it's
not afternoon or evening is changing
rather rapidly we've got some luck
it sounds like steve has also had some
luck and he's fouled hey Tony colored
cat well there we go everybody that's
what happens I told you we counted three
crossing the road and now we've come
further south and now two more of the
probably six tracks that we saw have
decided to get up from wherever they've
been slumbering here in the grasses and
unfortunately though they are deciding
to also cross the road now they seem to
be two of the youngsters of the Oklahoma
pride but I'm not certain there's not
too many characteristic features on them
but we go you see how now the tracks are
going to be in the middle of the road as
well as on the edge there and quite
fresh and it would easily be here comes
the third one on our left hand side so
definitely counted six tracks and here
comes number six so they'd probably
split up somewhere in the block there
and now and they've actually been on the
property all day it just goes to show
how difficult it is sometimes to find
animals there we go
why did the lioness cross the road
everybody because the wind was blowing
from that side sorry about that
it's another youngster
janitor does hard works my lions and
leopards suddenly they just come out of
the woodwork that everybody alas alas
alas that is some Bambi Lee on the other
side of the road and they are probably
going to go and join the rest of the
pride so at least our luck has paid off
we've been determined to check this
western boundary determined to move up
and down and suddenly out of nowhere my
heart skipped a beat as I suddenly saw
that beautiful golden tawny color Craig
and his head down ahead and seen I was
like it never gets all the senior lion
or a leopard suddenly would you be
looking for them for hours like that
well everybody that was very cool that's
the highlight of my afternoon I hope you
all enjoyed that very brief sighting of
the Lions but that's the way it works
Thank You lioness go often enjoy your
evening please come back again but you
can see how we were talking about the
wind back there and they've gone in that
direction so I know there are some of
you out there that disagree with me said
there's been thesis as proving things I
just go about what I've seen and
observed in my life and I always see
lions and leopards using the wind to
their advantage always so you disagree
let's agree to disagree but once again
they have gone in the exact direction
that the wind is kind of coming from if
not at a slight angle to it in search of
some food we're looking a little bit
hungry I wonder if any of you are able
to get any identification features off
of them there were definitely three
young lioness very likely of the uncle
whom our prides but then I have been
away all sorts of dynamic shifts are
going on at the moment like up in the
Mara it's very hard to identify lions up
there because they move move move okay
well we going to maybe give it another
moment yet maybe they're gonna turn
around and come back this way but while
we do that let's go and see how a shawl
is getting on looking for the rest of
the Julia
well done Steve I think that's awesome I
really did have a hope that we would see
those lions even though we knew that the
one had crushed earlier and I was really
hoping that it didn't mean that we
wouldn't see them for the whole day so I
am quite glad now I am approaching the
hyena den other den I don't want to get
too close to the entrance sometimes they
live right there and I don't want to
scare them so let's go around this way
this is nice you've been with me both
times that I've approached the den so
you get to see what I see when I get you
and what oh we have a little one we have
a little one with no mum around yet
again so quick glance for you all with a
pink light yes hello yes it's all about
the drive-by cuteness this afternoon cuz
we need to go it now again sorry poppet
no ribbons we all drive and speak oh no
no what are you getting so excited about
okay let's check around the other side
of the den to see maybe there'll be mom
around if not then we'll go the lovely
pink lights though don't you think
now ribbons been really interesting
lately because we've only seen the one
cub so far in the last two days because
I had her yesterday but something only
the one cub and then this morning Jamie
said the same thing only one cub
oh we are lucky I think I have found an
adult so I'm gonna stick around here in
the meantime let me send you over to
Tristan and Tanana the terrible tease I
hope wishes sake that she found an
adulterer pity that Steve unfortunately
loss of all had the Lions Crossing Levin
that they weren't coming our way anyway
we still with ting Ghana apparently
Trisha saying the terrible tease well I
don't know if we're the terrible teaser
I feel like we do well together ting
Ghana and myself I feel like we have a
good relationship and have had some good
sightings where he has he's been a
terrible terror today is what I'm gonna
call him with the way that he's walked
he's been a handful to try and kind of
keep up with and so you know not being
easiest to track down this afternoon but
luckily we've at least managed to catch
up the problem is is that he's heading
straight north now which means that he's
heading towards puffles Hook boundary
surprise surprise
always in you but some sort of a TV show
is I mean like that that you need to do
these cats will head as close to the
boundaries as possible and test your
kind of nerve as much as they can and so
we can't be surprised he's going to go
all the way and then you hit towards the
battlefield and he's gonna find an
aardvark all in sit sit sit or not move
the entire hour that we do a TV show so
should be an interesting we'll see how
it goes
so just going to be very patient and
very kind to us let us come through
which is very very nice where's ting
gonnigan though that's the next question
he seems to move off in France today
it's gonna become very tricky where we
going as well it comes as a lot thicker
as we move which is not ideal now while
we try and catch up with ting Ghana the
terrible which i think is a great Viking
name fort in Ghana
it seems you across to tree Sharla who's
managed to catch up with one of the
adult hyenas ting Ghana the terrible and
Tristan the tyrant what do you think
neither of them are either not that bad
at all
I promise it's more like Tristan the
treasure I hope I get a gold star for
that well we are sticking around because
ribbon is right at the base of the den
where shoes
hey rubes
she's been really tired these last few
days I've just seen her lying about but
she is still quite in attuned to what
her Cubs need because she's always
around and yesterday when she was about
to leave her cubs and actually walk off
with Koki she the little cub started to
whoop in the cutest little tiny whoop
I've ever heard high pitched oh it
sounded it was unbelievable I've only
ever heard it I think once Davi and I
had a similar type of thing but it was
just brief this was so close and full-on
whooping but in the squeaky squeaky
little calm voice and Reuben came
bounding back straight to her cub now
like I said we haven't seen the second
cabin in a couple days and after they
were playing rough and tough about two
or three days ago I think it was two
days ago they were playing quite rough
and tough and that was the last time I
saw them oh are you gonna jump jump fast
Oh what are you tryna gab you tryna grab
some leaves
it's a raisin bush that he's trying to
get at and they do have little raisins
or little berries but I really don't
think that that's what this cub is going
for you game believes you're practicing
you're pulling down kills move so
curious
now this cub is the darker one of
ribbons and I think it's actually the
smaller one even though it actually it
seems to dominate over the other cub but
it's actually smaller but you can tell
by its its behavior that's it's the
dominant one just the way it interacts
with the other cub
that stick is a bit big yeah that's a
big stick but you give it a good sizing
up yes they are Emma says they are a
destructive mission this evening I think
it's every evening Emma it's just a
matter of what's in their path of
destruction tonight can you imagine if
you were going to be destroyed by this
cute thing walking towards you you'd
never move its backs it's the best
strategy ever they're growing up so
wonderfully what happened you can see
we're stretching couldn't get the pot
couldn't get the pot and boom I love the
reaction after like what that was part
of my plan oh you keep on going like
that it's gonna happen again
this is what's getting this cub into
trouble it's stretching all the way
around losing its balance and tumbling
down
mrs. Lapp when you say that these guys
are just trouble
they are definitely trouble and like all
good troublesome kids they are too cute
that's the problem with them and so they
get troublesome because the acuteness
just overrides any sort of trouble they
can cause the well done you found a
better position in order to scratch your
leg when you won't tumble it up
it's almost like I'm waiting for the
next little bit of amusement that he's
gonna give us actually I think she I
don't know exactly the sex of the Cubs
yet or we don't know yet but I think
that they are both female but I am Not
sure in fact if you've got great pseudo
penis screenshots I'd love to see them
they often move around quite but it's
difficult to see but I mean even
researchers have it tough sometimes to
figure out the sexes up well there's
some more hyenas joining so while we
figure out who's come to join let's go
over to Justin Anton gana the terrible
tease again
well tonight he has just decided to stop
because he's been on a serious mission
and he's been kind of striding along and
I think we're going to be going again it
almost looks like he spotted something
now he's starting to just settle down a
little bit and maybe he's gonna kind of
put his bottom and have a bit of a sort
of race the problem is is where he is
he's in amongst a whole minefield of odd
farc holes and so I'm a bit hesitant to
move too far let's try it just get into
a slightly better position here genre
it's sort of be mindful of others as
well today in the society we're gonna
try our very best just to see if I can
get John Dre around a little bit tightly
unfortunately because of the stunts that
we have here John I'm afraid this is the
base that I can do for now we'll try and
figure out something just ah if the
stump wasn't checked would be fine we
could get around this little bush and
get a much better view of it but
unfortunately I've got two massive
stumps where I am at the moment and
that's making life a little bit tricky
but I was saying to you earlier that he
often likes to come in here because of
all of these odd [ __ ] holes and it seems
as though he's doing the exact same
thing that he always likes to do which
is basically he's walked into a sort of
whole bunch of of holes in the ground
then has now just set in his listening
and looking and I wouldn't if maybe
sometimes he hears something and that's
why he'll stop and look and listen for a
long period of time but it certainly
helps us because the way that he was
removing in the rate that he was moving
he was going to move out of humour
within the next ten minutes and so quite
glad that he's decided to stop and to
kind of find himself a bit of a bit of
spot to sit
chandre I don't remain you have many
options here I'm afraid even amongst the
real thickets at the moment ensuing
games have to have been obscured you of
Dingaan and other guys that are with me
they said that they've shown hid and so
he's not watching in parlors or dico
anything like that it seems as though
whatever he's watching is quite close to
him inside maybe one of these little
holes like I say often you'll just sit
and listen and we know that he can be
incredibly patient there was a few weeks
ago where we followed him here through
the night and we ended up leaving him I
sitting on the edge of one of these
holes in the next morning I came with
yen who is one of our freelance guides
and he was still sitting at the exact
same hole still watching and listening
and looking in so it can be that they
can be incredibly patient I mean they
want to be but he's gonna move off
through there I think he's trying to get
through this horrible Miss Jean Dre get
rid of that so we don't blind the people
on my rights inside and try and see if I
can figure out how she gets through here
in the meantime though it sends you back
across to Trish with her silly very
playful
my hangers are being very very silly no
I can't tell but I thought this was hot
just now when I saw the right ear looks
a little like any other adult that is
around some way it's pretty but she is
on the other side of just behind this
bush at the moment now this little cubby
is so energetic it's been bounding about
greeting everybody being very
enthusiastic and very very skittish
today a bit on edge too much coffee
it's so cute how when they see all the
adults come they want to be part of all
the the excitement as well I'm just
gonna move a little bit forward so we
can we're gonna roll actually hopefully
let's see if we can roll can we roll no
we can't okay okay no they're coming
back they're coming back this way
okay so that's what I'm looking for that
little notch on the right ear
Debra you say cuteness cuteness all
around
I think that's perfect description in
fact I think if you say that three times
in front of the mirror you yourself will
appear to be a cute hyena okay so we've
got a pretty and heart around you hello
you are right by me okay
just stuck my head down there
well you are looking quite fat
Oh your tummy is
consulting detective you would like to
know if this is the male cub to be
honest consulting detective I think in
fact with a name like that you should
tell me but I am I'm really not sure I'm
when having looked at them I thought
that they were both females but it is
difficult to tell in fact Jamey is the
best person to sex them but I didn't
think that they were both emails from
ribbons cubs I don't know if that feels
good or hurts when teeth in your mouth
yes you are a very strange species but
that is why you are so successful isn't
it because you are weirder than the rest
and that's why we love you
so when the adults are sort of doing
their thing these Cubs almost want to do
the same they want to just kind of be
involved I don't know when you a little
and/or well I was little and we just
sort of whatever the adults were doing
you wanted to be part of it too and you
wanted to be involved just like them and
these Cubs are much the same some enol
pasting going on there and then I bet
this cub is gonna come along and paste
there to butterfly you'd like to know
why they called Cubs and not pups
butterfly I really don't know what the
distinction is I would think that it
must have something to do with the
number in a litter I would think because
seals have pups dogs have pups Mongoose
have pups you don't know do you don't
know what the distinction is fact let me
know if you know and I can go and ask
somebody else and quiz them too it's a
lot going on everyone's come back to the
den it's lots of squeaking and nervous
laughing a little bit gigging anal
pasting it is just a party
this little cub is I'm telling you it's
drank a lot of coffee today because it
it is very hyperactive reminds me of a
little Jack Russell when it goes crazy
and stops are running around in circles
still watching everybody what are they
doing can I join but I'm a little bit
scared
what is this little flinch of the pseudo
penis as well I suppose it's a bit of a
motor reaction I guess
all right so you're still there
everything's just calmed down a little
bit but they have been anal pasting
about it's only amount of time until the
cub comes round and starts anal pasting
too so let me send you over to Steve at
least I think it was Steve Shore twisty
send you over to him if you end up with
tristin I'm sorry so funny what team
delaying is behave like that when the
adults emerge you just the joy and
excitement of getting involved and then
all the anal pasting that goes with it
so it sounds like it's a pickle Friday
night sorry that was me being being
cheeky
anyway we are just bumbling around the
darkness is descended you probably
notice we're in infrared spotlights out
light saw a blaze and are we going to
see what we can find this is a great
time of evening to just come across a
predator I think last night was about
this sort of time that Tristan just
bumbled bumped into Columba who just
materialized there might have been a
little bit earlier but that's what we
hope you for now we had tracks of a male
leopard and a female leopard in here we
had tracks of a female leopard on this
side so there was all sorts of tracking
going on today but as I said before it's
quite tricky sometimes if if you lose
the tracks because of maybe some vehicle
movement on the roads and then you just
got to move into that area work that
area at night and then as what we've
seen many times in the past those
animals just pop out obviously the damn
cam is quite helpful in that regard and
so are the baboons and all the others
that alarm calling around the day and
that helped the others to find the Duke
of juba so we're gonna just continue on
down here
we're gonna head back down and maybe
just go see if anything's going on
around the watering hole of the name a
treehouse cuz you never know it could be
something hanging around there
okay.we before all the noise dies down
let's go back over to the juma den where
all the action is happening
hold the noise has died down so the
adults have just left I just want to
take a quick drive around the den so we
can look if they are just hiding around
like ribbon was earlier whether they are
actually gone now this little one
whooped that cute very high-pitched
whoop for us of course as soon as you
cut away that's it's exactly when it
will happen but the last time it did
that the adults came a-runnin back so
I'm just wondering okay let's go around
this way
oh yes you are hello hello ribbon
alrighty let's turn around then let's go
round again do you know how many times
I've paid ring around the hanging it in
plenty of times now that's why I say
ribbon is such a great mom because she
reacts so quickly when her cub calls for
her
hey girlie girl
okay there are two adults yet no one
just you see when sometimes when you
drive really close to them these two
some of you new viewers are wondering
why it's important to be at the den or
to not leave the den when they aren't
any adults around I'm just gonna move as
I answer your question well that's
because the Cubs are still quite
vulnerable and they will run straight
into the hole of the day I know the
entrance of the den when something
threatens them or they feel scared but
we don't want to be the reason for that
happening because Cubs are really really
curious and they will often come up to
the car to the point it will come up to
my feet and they behave in that
comfortable way in this an adult that's
not around they may do that come out and
be attacked by something and we really
really don't want that for obvious
reasons so that's why we try to keep our
presence here only when there are adults
around you see as a natural defense Cubs
enter into their den but when they are
curious about us they sometimes forget
about that all righty
and we're back where we were who do we
have you let's go forward a little bit
no I was trying to get your face back a
little bit okay no you move for me okay
fine you move for me no see they're
going to make me do this and I'm gonna
have to go ring around this hyena den
until I find an adult and a [ __ ] who
they will be there you're just trying to
make oh okay listen there's still
somebody here yay it's just on my other
side I think it's ribbon because ribbon
was around when the cub called hello oh
you were suddenly very dirty or very
full of grass but you nose is still
quite wet this is not dripping no she
looks like she's gonna fall asleep so
soon no no no I'm not I'm not I promise
I'm looking after my child
so she has spent most of her days in
this exact position oh hi Steve has
found a hyena hyena did not find Steve
so let's go over to him and see who he's
got there we have found something in the
darkness indeed we have indeed we have
and it is a hyena that was walking
directly away from the juma den where
Trish is currently and it's come to
drink a treehouse damn so our
anticipation for trying to find
something by the watering hole has paid
off because what animals need to do they
need to drink it is part and parcel of
being a mammal and many other animals
need to drink of course but we are
dependent on water for our survival and
how incredible is it having a look at
the thermal imaging in the drinking
hyena very thirsty I'm trying to get an
identification of this individual and I
need to just go through my my
screenshots
she had a nip Nick in the top left yeah
but haven't quite yet I have been out of
town so my my memory of all of them is a
little bit wanting so I have to go
through the screenshots then I took just
double check I can tell you for sure
it's not a ribbon because Trisha sitting
with ribbon
I think it might have been pretty but
I'm not sure she's got a nick in the
top-left here I think that is pretty
you've got a very large belly and
definitely pretty I know that now I
comes back to me Corky's got the nick in
the left ear as well as the little
earring and then pretty has got adjust
the Nick in the top of the air so the
reflections are very interesting and I
find it quite strange why there is a
reflection so the camera is a thermal
camera now how is it picking up an image
there can't be a heat reflected image I
don't know it's way beyond my my
scientific mind to figure out look at
that bulging belly look how full it is
how warm it is and in the infrared you
can barely even see her so it just goes
to show how valuable the tools that we
have here armed with the FLIR and now
all you can basic to see in the infrared
is a bit of end all right and so that is
pretty coming down to drink calipers you
haven't seen you in some time isn't she
special she walked right past the car
with us before but that we're a little
bit far off for the infrared now so
she's probably gonna go off and who
knows where's she gone she's gone just
like that just like that and she's right
there she's in the same place she is in
the same place she was before just on
the other side of the watering hole well
everybody I hope you've had a wonderful
afternoon oh this has been really nice
being out lots of interesting
information I hope you have a fantastic
evening we will see you again tomorrow
morning a thanks to everybody involved
and we will have a beautiful TV show
coming up soon you have a beautiful
night so that good night thank you and
goodbye
[Music]